So far in this course, we've discussed how to
acquire, munge, and analyze data. These are all really important
skill sets for a data scientist to have. However,
an equally important skill is the ability to communicate your
findings. Sure, this can be done through a presentation
or through a blog post. But, one of the most
effective ways to communicate your findings is through a data
visualization. During this lesson we'll be focusing on the basics
of data visualization. We'll talk about how to use
a variety of visual cues to encode information and also
how to make concise and effective visualizations that really
communicate what you're trying to say. We'll also go over
how to make some of these different types of
visualizations in Python. Once you have these skills, you'll be
able to take the findings that we've accumulated about the
New York City subway system. And really make effective visualizations
that communicate these findings either to your friends, or your
family. Or, anyone else. All right, why don't we begin?